Welcome, students, to
Clinical
Pharmacokinetics.
This is the clinical
application of
pharmacokinetics
for rational dosing
and the time course
of drug action.
This screen says part
one. There is a part two.
Really, it is one
lecture that takes longer
than 50 minutes
because of the content.
And all the concepts
are interrelated.
Please contact
me if you'd like
to chat about
pharmacology.
Learning objectives.
These are the concepts
that you need to know
to understand clinical
pharmacokinetics.
Practice questions. I
highly, highly recommend.
I've included required
here. students
over the years have
told me how helpful
they are not only
for helping you learn
pharmacology but
also for the boards.
Some suggestions
on effective
learning strategies.
There are resources if
you wish to use them.
A rational approach
to achieving a
desired beneficial
effect with minimum
adverse effects.
That's optimization of
therapy for your
individual patient.
The drug monographs
have starting points
but you will need
to understand these
basic pharmacokinetic
concepts, these
fundamental pharmacokinetic
concepts in order
to optimize for your
particular patient.
This figure
represents the
interrelationship
between all of the
pharmacokinetic
parameters, administration,
absorption, distribution,
elimination, either
as metabolism or
excretion, and the
amount of drug that gets
to the site of
action to produce its
clinical effect. And
a clinical response
can be effectiveness,
certainly that's
what we're looking
for, but it can also
include toxicity.
These are mechanisms
of action and
mechanisms of toxicity.
So when I talk
about mechanisms,
mechanisms, mechanisms, I
mean all of
these mechanisms,
pharmacokinetic and
pharmacodynamic.
What you need to
know and understand,
I'm not going to go
through each of these.
I put these tables
here to help you.
It really is a
learning tool to help
remind you of what
these concepts are.
You will need to
understand all of these
concepts in order
to be able to apply
pharmacokinetic
fundamentals to dosing.
Some more, plenty plenty
of fundamental concepts
and more.
These really are
all relationships.
I'm not going
to ask you to
calculate anything
except loading dose
and maintenance
dose. These you will
need to know how
to calculate. The
others are relationships,
meaning that
the parameters are
related to each
other, either
directly or inversely.
So please Always
look at all of
those equations
as relationships.
And some more terms
that you'll need to
understand when you're
talking pharmacology to
each other as students
and as practitioners.
Here are some
variables, so we look
into the drug
monographs to get some
pharmacokinetic
information and of
course pharmacodynamic
information too.
These listings in the
monographs are for
patients with normal
renal function,
normal liver function,
and many patients
have conditions
that can change the
parameters. And that's
what you need to be
able to understand
when you read the
pharmacokinetics in
the drug monographs.
Fortunately, they
include renal
dosing, hepatic
dosing, so
that you don't
have to guess.
I'm going to talk
a moment about
therapeutic
drug monitoring.
so we think okay I
can tell if my patient
has the right amount of
drug just by measuring
it in the bloodstream
well yes we can
do that for a number
of drugs and it is
helpful but we can't
do it for every drug
for example if a
person is taking an
antihypertensive for blood
pressure we just nearly
merely need to measure
the blood pressure
to see if the drug is
effective For other
drugs, we can measure
the blood levels.
But this is good
only when there is a
relationship between
the concentration
of drug in the plasma
and the effect.
If there is
significant variability
between patients and
within one patient,
if there is
an established
drug target
concentration.
If there isn't, we
can get our drug
concentration level
back, but what
do we do with it
if we don't know
what the target
concentration is?
Drugs with a narrow
therapeutic window,
so they have a
potential for
getting up into
toxicity zone.
So we can,
assuming all of
these other features,
then we can
avoid toxicity,
hopefully, in the
individual patient
by measuring the
blood levels.
Excuse me, I pushed
the wrong button.
And all of this
is fine only if
there is a reliable,
cost-effective
drug assay for
clinical use.
If not, we're
not going to be
able to measure
the drug levels.
So, in summary,
only clinically
meaningful when the
efficacy of a drug
treatment can be enhanced
by achieving a certain
concentration or
effect range, and
or toxicity of drug
therapy could be
reduced by maintaining
a certain concentration
or effect range.
That's when we use it.
Some fundamental
principles that
I'm actually
going to go over
with you. Benefit
versus risk.
The benefit must always
outweigh the risk.
We're not going
to use a toxic
chemotherapy for
a minor problem.
However,
a toxic
chemotherapy may be
appropriate for
a cancer patient
who would die
without treatment.
Dosing. The smallest
dose necessary to produce
the desired effect.
Remember the concept
of the dose determines
the concentration
in the blood, which
determines the concentration
at the effector site,
which determines
the magnitude of the
effect. So the smallest
dose necessary to
produce the desired
effect. You don't want
to use a dose so small
that there's no observable
clinical effect.
Treatment regimen.
The number of medications
that a patient
is getting and how
many doses per day
the patient is
getting should be
minimized to improve
adherence to therapy.
If the
therapeutic regimen
is complicated
by lots of
medications and lots
of doses, patients
are not going
to want to be on
those therapies.
Furthermore, the
more medications
a patient takes,
the more potential
for drug
interactions and more
potential for
adverse drug events.
Now changing
drug regimens, we
need to be
careful with that.
Many drugs need to be
cautiously reduced in
dosage over time.
Many drugs need to be
cautiously increased
in dosage over time to
prevent the adverse
reactions that
abrupt withdrawal
or starting with
high doses may cause.
We always need to
be thinking about
the potential drug
-drug interactions
and drug-disease
interactions.
Now, people are
different, and
genetics may play a
role in determining
the variability
in drug response.
Some of the pharmacogenomic,
pharmacogenetic
screening tests
are available and
are reasonably priced
and are useful.
They should be used
when they are useful.
Knowledge.
Well, practitioners
need to keep up with
the literature. But
you're busy, busy,
busy, busy, and that's
difficult. So at least
try and keep up
with the guidelines.
These are generally
unbiased opinions from
experts that formulate
these guidelines.
And they provide
a foundation
for decision making.
There are some
websites that
are excellent,
highly reliable,
like UpToDate
at this point.
so be sure you know
the website you're
using is reliable and
also if you have time
join journal clubs
basically prescribers
should only use a
limited number of drugs
with which they are
thoroughly familiar
you don't need to
memorize thousands of
drugs we have literature
for that We have
drug monographs that
will tell you all
you need to know about
particular drugs.
But within your practice
scope, you should
be thoroughly familiar
with the drugs,
what they do,
their mechanisms of
action, their
pharmacokinetic
parameters, and your
experience with their
use in a variety
of patients. So
let's get into it.
Here are the parameters
that govern drug
disposition, in
other words
pharmacokinetics, clearance,
bioavailability,
volume of
distribution,
elimination, half-life.
These are considered
the major parameters
and area under the
concentration versus
time curve and steady
state are related.
In fact, all of
these parameters
are related
to each other.
Let's take a very
simple example.
This is Models of Drug
Distribution
and Elimination.
If you want to
look into it
further, it is
in the Basic and
Clinical Pharmacology
textbook.
I have given
you that link at
the beginning
of the lectures.
So looking at Panel A,
a very simple example
of a one compartment
model. We have the
beaker, which is the
container of blood,
and we have drug being
introduced into that
blood and instantaneously
distributing.
On the right side,
we have the y-axis,
which is the
concentration of drug
in the blood over
time on the x-axis.
The drug is introduced
into the blood to
a certain peak level
and because there is
no outlet there is a
straight line across.
Now let's take
the more realistic
example where there
is elimination
going on at
the same time.
That's indicated here.
The drug is introduced
into the blood,
immediately
distributes in the
volume, and
immediately, well almost
immediately, begins
to be eliminated.
So drug goes into the
blood, certain peak
concentration, and
elimination over time.
drip, drip, drip.
Now, a more
realistic model
of a two
-compartment model.
Drug goes in,
notice that the
elimination valve here is
closed, immediately
distributes in the central
compartment, the blood,
and then distributes
in an equilibrium
to the extravascular
volume. So what is the
extravascular volume?
That's the interstitial
fluid, and drugs that
have the capacity to
cross cellular barriers
can also distribute
into cells and tissues.
we get a peak then
we get a distribution
phase and because
the elimination valve
is closed we get
a plateau here but
that's not what happens
in our bodies we
put drug into our
body and as it passes
by the liver it gets
metabolized eliminated
by a metabolism as
it passes by the
kidneys it gets
excreted in the kidneys.
We get drug in,
distribution,
drug out, peak,
the distribution
phase, and
then the
elimination phase.
That's a basic concept.
That's what happens
with drugs. This is
a very simple model
but it's easy to
see what's going on.
Of course, we're
not just two models.
This is a picture of
a multi-compartment
model where the
drug goes into the
blood, distributes to
the vessel-rich group
like the brain and
the viscera, then
more slowly distributes
to the muscle mass
and even more slowly
to the fat mass.
Before administration, in
this figure,
there is no drug.
Immediately after
administration, as it goes
to the vessel-rich
group, the brain and
viscera, you can see that
on this little figure.
You see little blood
vessels throughout.
And after
distribution and
equilibrium. You
see the blood has
distributed to
the body at large.
And here it is in
the graph with the
distribution phase,
which is this slope here
of the distribution
phase is referred
to alpha, so the
distribution phase is
referred to alpha.
And the elimination
phase, this slope is
referred to beta, so
the elimination phase
is the beta phase.
That is the language
of pharmacology.
Now, that's all fine
and good, but what if
there is a change in
blood flow to the various
tissues? Well, that's
going to change the
rate of drug distribution
to the tissues.
Thus, the effect of
a drug at various
sites of action
can vary depending
on the perfusion
of these sites. So
if there's reduced
perfusion, there's
going to be less
drug delivered.
Clearance.
Very, very
important concept.
Really all drugs, all
drug pharmacokinetic
concepts are circle
around clearance.
Clearance is
a total thing.
We think of
clearance through the
kidneys with excretion,
certainly clearance
through the liver
with metabolism,
but there can be
clearance through
these other routes of
bile, sweat, saliva,
breast milk, lungs,
if it's gases.
It's not a lot that
goes out that way.
So we really,
when we're talking
about clearance,
basically we're
talking about
these two routes.
But we must not forget
that the drugs can go out
in the fluids through
these other routes.
Clearance depends,
first of all, on the
drug. What are the
properties of the drug?
That will determine
how it is cleared.
The blood flow, which
I mentioned, and
the condition of the
organs of elimination
in the patient.
How healthy are
the kidneys? How
healthy is the liver?
Clearance is the
proportionality factor
that predicts the
rate of elimination
in relation to the
drug concentration.
So we have a
starting point.
The rate of drug
elimination is
directly proportional
to the concentration
when clearance
is constant.
Here is the
relationship here.
Clearance equals the
rate of drug elimination.
I put milligrams per
minute but it could
be liters per
hour to the drug
concentration in the
measured fluid and we're
usually thinking
about blood plasma
serum could be urine
but we're going to
confine ourselves
to thinking about it
in the central
compartment the blood.
And I put milligrams
per milliliter
here. It could be
different units,
but I want to point
out we have to
factor in the weight
of the patient.
Now, rearranging
this equation, drug
elimination rate equals
clearance times the
concentration in the
blood, in the plasma,
in the serum, whatever
we're measuring.
At the steady state,
which I will talk
about in more detail
in the second part,
the dosing rate equals
the rate of elimination.
Therefore, the dosing
rate equals clearance
times concentration
in the blood
at steady state. And
this is the form that
we are going to be
using after this.
Dosing rate equals
clearance times
the concentration
at steady state.
Steady state is the
dynamic equilibrium
that occurs with
continuous dosing.
And the rate in
equals the rate out.
The rate of drug
elimination equals
the rate of drug
administration.
Dynamic equilibrium
between the
blood and the
various tissues,
the blood and the
plasma proteins
in the blood, it's all in
dynamic equilibrium,
steady state.
We'll talk about
these three
parameters now,
extraction ratio,
bioavailability, and
the area under the
concentration
versus time curve.
Extraction ratio.
So what's extraction
to begin with?
Extraction is
the ability of
an organ to remove
active drug.
Simply that.
The extraction
ratio is a clearance
model of an
organ's intrinsic
capacity, its
ability to remove,
metabolize, excrete
a particular drug.
So intrinsic capacity
for eliminating
a particular drug
in a single pass
through the organ
at steady state.
And I have a
figure on the next
slide that will
illustrate this.
First, let's introduce
you to the relationship.
So, how do we come
up with the amount
of drug that is
actually passing
through that organ
of elimination?
Well, we measure how
much is going in and
how much comes out at
the other end, and divide
it by the total amount
that's going in.
Now, extraction
ratio also depends
on blood flow,
Q, blood flow.
So clearance
equals the blood
flow times this
extraction here.
And that's going to
give us clearance
equals blood flow
times the extraction.
And rearranging, this
is our extraction ratio.
So,
extraction equals
clearance of that
particular organ
divided by blood
flow to that
particular organ.
We are talking now about
the unbound fraction
of drug in the plasma
because it is only
the unbound fraction or
the free fraction that
is able to pass into
the liver and be
metabolized, pass into the
kidneys and be excreted
move to the target
organ the effector
organ so we're talking
about unbound fraction.
Intrinsic clearance is
the intrinsic ability
of clearance mechanisms
of the organs so
we think about with
the liver the hepatic
enzymes for example
and then the kidneys
it's various excretory
processes. So how
well does the organ
clear a particular drug?
Here's the
illustration. We'll
start with the oral dose.
Now the person swallows
the drug and it goes
through the stomach
and it goes into the
small intestine and it
may not be completely
absorbed and it goes
on through to the
gut or it might be
pumped back out by p
-glycoprotein and it
goes through the gut so
there's certain amount
that may not be absorbed
and whatever gets
absorbed will go into
the portal circulation
and on it goes to the
liver and this partal
circulation is blood
so there's a certain
blood flow that is
bringing the absorbed
concentration of drug
into the liver so here
we have concentration
in now within the liver
a certain amount is
going to be metabolized
there are a few
drugs that actually are
not very extensively
metabolized in the
liver but most drugs are
metabolized to a
certain extent so they
would be inactive that's
what we're going to
be talking about
elimination by the liver
means conversion
biotransformation of a drug
from its active form
to its inactive form
That's for now,
that's not, as you
may remember when
we talked about
metabolism, there are
various things that
can happen, but
this is what we're
talking about for
this illustration.
Now on the other side,
we have blood flow
after the liver and
the concentration that
comes out. So C in
minus C out divided
by C in. And this is
the fraction that gets
into the systemic
circulation. So this
is the amount of drug
that's bioavailable.
Now the drug will travel
around, passes
by the kidneys.
there will be clearance
by the kidneys,
renal excretion
of the drug or
a certain fraction
of the drug.
We see the extraction
ratio here for renal.
I'm sorry I keep pushing
the wrong button.
And whatever else
travels around. Another
dose is given at the
appropriate time and
on and on and on. Now,
let's say we're giving
an intravenous dose
of the same drug,
goes into the vein,
goes through the heart,
goes into the
arterial system, gets
distributed to the body,
including passing by the
kidney, and passing
through the liver.
So this is the one pass
through C in, C out,
C in to the kidney,
C out of the kidney.
We get a certain
amount in the systemic
circulation and on
and on. So we see
that the extraction
ratio applies to
drugs by any route
of administration.
I which will pass
through the liver,
and a certain amount
will be extracted.
It could be 90%
extracted, so only
10% gets in. That
would be not great.
It could be 50%
extracted, so 50%
gets in. It could
be 10% extracted.
So 90% comes out
the other side.
That's going to depend
on the specific drug.
Drug A, drug B, drug
C, whatever it is.
Most drugs fall kind
of in a range sort of
in the middle. They
get extracted, but
they also have reasonable
bioavailability.
the big f capital
f stands for the
bioavailability
that's fraction that
comes out after
passing through the
organ and the small
f refers to the fraction
that gets absorbed
the explanation of
of the blood flow
bringing drug to the
organ of elimination,
liver mainly, is
what we think about.
So the amount of
drug that gets
to the organ of
elimination is
going to depend
on the blood flow.
Now, what if
the liver is not
functional? What if
it's fibrotic? It's
got a patient who
has cirrhosis.
Well,
the liver is not
functioning. The blood
is going to pass
right really by the,
it's going to shunt
past the liver. And
as a result, if a drug,
let's say, normally
drug A is 90%
extracted by the liver
so that it's got a
10% bioavailability,
well now the liver
is not extracting.
What is the bioavailability
going to be?
It could be very, very
much larger. Let's
say 100% now of the
dose goes out into
the systemic circulation.
That's 10 times.
And that could cause
some serious toxicity.
Well, let's say drug B
has very little hepatic
extraction, and its
bioavailability normally
is 90%, and if the
liver is fibrotic and
blood passes really
right by the liver, It's
shunted past the liver,
and now let's say
it's 100%, just using
extremes as examples.
It's only slightly more
bioavailable for drug B.
We still have to think
about it, though.
And the same
concept goes for the
kidneys. If the blood
flow to the kidneys
is reduced, such
as with heart
failure or low kidney
function, chronic
kidney disease,
then less of a dose
will be excreted
through the kidneys.
Which brings us to
renal extraction, the
fraction of active drug
excreted in the urine.
we have blood going
into the kidney through
the afferent arteriole
passes through the
glomerulus this is a
bunch of capillaries
in here and they
capillaries filter the
plasma and here is the
artery coming out the
efferent renal artery
and from the efferent
then there are a peritubular
capillary network
that really just
surround the nephron.
Therefore, the
fraction of active drug
excreted in the
urine is dependent
on the renal blood
flow, obviously,
the protein binding,
because only free drug
is going to pass
through the glomerulus,
and how functional
are the nephrons.
The glomerular
filtration rate is
going to depend on
renal blood flow
and the health of
the glomerulus.
About 20% of free
drug, certain drugs
that are dissolved
in plasma, can pass
through the glomerulus
at any given
time because only
about 20% of the plasma
is filtered on one
pass-through. Now,
whatever drug comes
out, goes around,
and can enter the nephron
through transporters.
Whatever drug enters
the nephron and
passes through,
this representation
is not what the
nephron actually looks
like, it's just
a representation.
will pass through and
if the drug can pass
through physiologic
barriers has
lipophilicity it'll pass
back into the bloodstream
it'll be reabsorbed
and then whatever
is left will be
excreted in the urine.
So to review renal
clearance is affected
by renal blood flow
protein binding, function
of the nephrons, the
glomerular filtration
rate, the secretion
rate from the
peritubular fluid
into the nephron,
and reabsorption
from the nephron
back into the blood,
and that is however
much gets extracted.
Bioavailability,
I've mentioned this a
few times now, it is
indicated by a capital
F. It is the fraction
of active drug
that reaches this
systemic circulation.
That's also
referred to as
the central compartment.
Dose, well obviously
the dose is going to
determine the
bioavailability. It's a low
dose, smaller amount
gets into the systemic
circulation. High
dose, a larger amount.
And the fraction
of the dose that is
absorbed and escapes
first pass elimination.
So, absorbed here,
we're talking
about oral most
frequently.
Ah, sorry.
So, bioavailability
equals
the amount that
gets absorbed.
One minus extraction,
and that's going to
give us some number
between 0.0 to 0.99 to 1.
1 equals 100%. So
it's going to reduce
absorption and complete
release of the drug
from the dosage
form. If it's not
released from the tablet
or the capsule or
whatever dosage form,
it's going to just
pass through the gut.
for drugs that are
unable to cross
physiologic barriers
or have a low ability
there will be more
drug that does not
get absorbed efflux
by p-glycoprotein
and other efflux
transporters it gets
dumped right back
out of the intestinal
cells epithelial cells
back into the gut
and intestinal
epithelium has the
capacity of actually
metabolizing
drug. So if it gets
metabolized in the
gut epithelial
cells, it's not going
to reach the
portal circulation.
Bioavailability
must be factored
into the oral
dosing calculations.
The example that's
frequently used
is verapamil, which is an
antihypertensive
drug, antiarrhythmic.
It has both capacities.
And we're using an
extraction ratio of 0.67
two-thirds because it's
easy to talk about.
Verapamil
actually has quite
a range of
bioavailabilities.
This is why you need to
monitor your patient.
So the expected oral
bioavailability would
be 1 minus 0.7, 1 minus
the extraction, and
that results in 0.33,
F equals 0.33, which
is 33%. Okay, what
do we do with that
information? So, the
dosing rate calculation is
clearance times steady
state concentration.
But we have
to divide that
by the bioavailability.
So, with this
verapamil example,
well, IV is always
going to be 100%
no matter what. f
equals 1, which is
sometimes omitted
because it is 1.
We have our IV
dose. Let's say
it's 5 milligrams
per hour.
That's going to be in
a 24-hour period. The
patient will have
received 120 milligrams.
So we want to figure
out the oral dose
because we want to
send the patient
home on the oral
drug. Been stabilized.
I want to keep
that drug level
within the
therapeutic range.
So we figure out the
dose that the patient's
been getting, divided
by the bioavailability,
and the patient's
been getting this
over 24 hours, that's
the total amount,
divided by the
bioavailability, and that
will bring us to 360
milligrams, and we
can give the patient
an extended release
tablet once a day, or
a capsule once a day.
Area under the
concentration time curve.
The AUC integrates
the concentration
of drug and plasma
over time, and that
will tell us the
total body exposure of
the patient, of the
body, to a dose of
drug. And this is
figured out either
for a single dose
or, more frequently,
for one dosing interval
at steady state.
Dose is given,
reaches a peak, and
is gradually
eliminated over time.
This would be a trough
level is taken here.
and all these
dots represent
samples, blood
samples taken and
the concentration
determined.
Clearance may be
estimated from AUC.
It's not a definition of
clearance, but
it's an estimation.
Using this concept,
clearance equals dose
divided by the steady
state concentration.
Therefore,
clearance would equal the
dose divided by the AUC.
This is the amount
of drug that
the patient has
been exposed
to in a given
amount of time.
In this case, it would
be a 12-hour period.
The bioavailability
of a drug determines
this concentration
in plasma, right?
which over time
determines the actual body
exposure of the drug.
So what relationships
are we seeing here?
We're seeing the
bioavailability of the
drug, because that's the
concentration in the
systemic circulation,
and clearance. So
how are we using
this idea of AUC?
There is a clinical
application for it.
So here are a couple
of definitions again.
Absolute bioavailability
and we can remember
absolute because we're
comparing it to the
IV dose which is
absolutely bioavailable,
100% bioavailable. So
we'll compare Or the
drug given intravenously
by the same drug given
by another root, such
as the oral root. Or
it could be subcutaneously,
or intramuscularly,
or transdermally,
but some other root.
We used oral in
this example.
by dividing the area
under the concentration
versus time curve
for the oral dose
by the IV dose, we
will come up with our
absolute bioavailability.
Okay, that's
great. That helps us.
And when we look at
the drug monographs
and we see the
bioavailability of a
particular dosage form,
it's based on this
concept clinical
application we saw
that with verapamil
clinical application now
relative bioavailability
just means comparing the
bioavailability of different
formulations of the
same drug for example
we want to compare
the tablet the
capsule the solution
and the drug
companies do this
and tell us the relative
bioavailabilities
and the relative dosing.
So if I am giving
my patient a
tablet form and
I want to switch
the patient over
to the solution,
am I going to be able
to do it dose per
dose or is it going
to have a different
dose for the solution
than for the tablet?
another very very
common application of
relative bioavailability
is comparing the
same drug in the same
dosage forms made by
different companies
the branded drug comes
out first and
there's a lot of
pharmacokinetic information
on that and then over
time after the patent
expires then generic
tablets can come out
generic tablets or
capsules or whatever
the dosage form and
we want to know is
the bioavailability of
the generic exactly
the same as that of
the branded product
because if it is and
it demonstrates safety
and efficacy then
we can confidently
prescribe the generic,
which is cheaper,
more cost
-effective than the
brand name drug.
So that's relative
bioavailability,
two ways of looking at
it. Now I have
an illustration.
In this example,
and this is from the
Basic and Clinical
Pharmacology textbook,
We have drug A,
which is rapidly
and completely
available. So what
would that be?
The IV, of course.
Drug A curve is here.
And the area under
the concentration
versus time curve
is calculated.
Now let's look
at drug C because
that one's right
underneath.
drugs completely available
but the rate only
half of a so this
could be an oral drug
that actually is completely
absorbed but it's
going to be entering
the body much more
slowly and then we see
that the elimination rate
is approximately the
same the rate I mean
the ****** now B is
only half the available
availability of a but
the rate is equal to
a so here's the rate
and see the rate is the
same but the bioavailability
let's say it's
a solution and the
solution is not as well
absorbed is much lower
and the area under
the concentration time
curve is much lower.
So that's a way to
apply the AUC when
comparing the same
drug to different
formulations or the
same drug in the same
formulation made by a
different manufacturer.
Moving now to the
apparent volume
of distribution,
the volume D.
In this simple model
of a single homogeneous
compartment
where the dose is
administered and
immediately distributes to
the entire volume
and we get clearance.
So dose end,
distribution immediately,
and elimination.
Volume of distribution
is the proportionality
constant that
relates the total
amount of drug in the
body volume to the
plasma concentration
at a given time.
Volume equals
the dose divided
by the
concentration in the
measured fluid,
blood or plasma.
The drug has to
get into the blood
or plasma, the
central compartment,
in order to
be distributed
around the body.
This is a calculation,
so it is an
apparent or a
theoretical volume.
You may hear about
drugs that have a
volume of distribution
of 5,000 liters.
Well, clearly, bodies
are not that big,
which is why it's
an apparent volume.
But of course,
we are not a
single
distributive model.
We saw this before
where drug goes
into blood and at
the same time is
starting to
distribute to these
other tissues, but
much more slowly.
and this concept of
volume of distribution
is important when
we're talking
about the amount of
drug in the blood.
In our top panel
these wiggly lines
in the pink portion
Distribution
represents the
plasma proteins, and
there are two units
of blood that are
given, drug A,
according to this.
Now volume of
distribution
equals the amount
of drug in the
body divided by
concentration,
so dose divided by Cp.
And the drug will
now distribute
out of the central
compartment, out
of the blood,
into the tissues,
and this will be in
equilibrium at
steady state.
Back and forth and
back and forth.
So let's, this is 18
units in tissue, so
let's calculate the
volume of distribution.
Total 18 plus 2, so
20 liters divided by
2, which is what the
amount in the blood,
equals 10 liters.
So the volume of
distribution in the top
example is 10 liters.
Just to remind you,
the drug is not
bound to any plasma
proteins, not bound
to any tissue proteins.
It's just moving
back and forth
between the blood and
the tissue in a
dynamic equilibrium.
So let's take the
second example now.
Same number of
units, but now the
drug is bound to
plasma proteins.
18 units worth
of that dose are
bound to the
plasma proteins.
Remembering, here's
one that's not bound,
here's another one
that's not bound,
remembering that when
a drug is bound to
plasma proteins it's
riding around on
the albumin bus could
be other proteins
but it's usually
albumin so when it's
riding around on the
albumin bus it's not
going into the liver
to be metabolized
it's not going through
the kidney to be
excreted and it's
not moving into
the tissues or
to the side of
action it's just
riding the bus
So in this case, we
do measure how much
drug is in the
vascular compartment
because we're measuring
how much is the
total amount on plasma
proteins and free.
Two units have
made it into
the tissue compartment.
So the volume of
distribution is 20
divided by 18 liters,
which is 1.1 liters.
So let's compare that.
10 liters when the
drug is just freely
moving back and forth
because it's not bound
to anything compared to
one liter when it remains
in the blood so if
you see a volume of
distribution that's a
low amount then you
know that that drug is
remaining largely in
the vascular compartment
and now our final
example in which
two units of blood
remains in the blood
it is not bound to
anything this is
an example of 200
units now have
been given because
so much is bound to
proteins and
macromolecules in
the tissues. It
is sequestered
in the tissues,
so it is not
being metabolized. It
is not being excreted.
It is not moving to
the site of action.
So we have 200 liters
now divided by two,
which leaves a volume
of distribution of
100 liters. So when
you see a huge volume
of distribution, it
means that a large
fraction of the drug
is in the tissues.
That's basically
the whole concept.
So you might need to
be able to calculate
the volume of
distribution. You
should absolutely
know what it means.
If you see a volume
of distribution
calculation on a board
exam, for example,
I'm sure it'll be
an easy one that
you can actually
do in your head.
It is the concept
you need to remember.
Low volume of
distribution,
blood stays in drug.
High volume of
distribution,
drug is in tissues.
This is the simplest
explanation.
When plasma protein
binding is reversible,
which it is 99
.99999% of the time,
a chemical equilibrium
exists between
bound and unbound
drugs. So here we have
our dynamic equilibrium
concept again.
At the top we see a
free drug molecule
and we see all those
molecules now bound
to plasma protein
and it will, based on
the affinity of the
protein for the drug,
the drug for the protein,
it will associate,
dissociate,
associate, dissociate.
Looking at panel B,
drug and plasma
can pass through to
the tissues and pass
back, it's going
to be in dynamic
equilibrium, and
as the drug becomes
unbound, and
this is a dynamic
equilibrium again,
as it becomes unbound,
it can pass into
the tissues, and another
drug molecule will
bind to that plasma
protein binding site.
The point is that the
equilibrium between
bound and free drug
gets re-established.
Now we talk about
drug-drug interactions
and we think about
how important is
it if a drug is now
going to, drug B,
is going to displace
drug A from the
plasma protein. So
if drug B takes the
place of drug A because
it's got a higher
affinity for the
plasma protein, we
now have more drug
A that is free, a
higher concentration
of unbound drug A.
Now, an equilibrium will
again be reestablished
between the amount
of drug A in blood
and the amount
that actually gets
excreted. And this is
based on the rate of drug
metabolism is directly
proportional to
the free drug concentration
and the fraction
of drug that is
removed is constant.
We'll get into this
more in the second part
when we talk about
first order kinetics.
So the increase in
free fraction will
increase the apparent
clearance of the drug,
but the steady state
would not change.
So I will put this
here because we're
talking about plasma
protein, but we will talk
about steady state,
first-order kinetics,
and clearance in Part
2, as I mentioned.
What do we need to
think about for our
individual patient?
Changes in protein binding
due to disease states
and drug interactions
are clinically
relevant, mainly for a
small subset of
drugs with a narrow
therapeutic window and
a high potential for
toxicity. This is what
we're thinking about.
For example,
let's see if I
can find a place
to write here.
if we have a drug with
a huge therapeutic
window and the steady
state concentration is
right in here somewhere
and the drug gets
displaced and the steady
state concentration
moves up here
temporarily because a new
equilibrium will be
established then it's
not likely to be a
problem in the average
patient but let's say
this therapeutic window
is really narrow and
there are certain
drugs that have really
narrow therapeutic
windows and significant
toxicity if drug
concentration is in here
and now they get displaced
the drug concentration
can be up here.
That's when we
really care about the
displacement from
plasma proteins.
So in summary, the
plasma concentration
is a function of the
rate of input of the
drug, the dose, by
absorption into the
plasma, the rate of
distribution into other
tissues, and the
rate of elimination.
So, dose absorption,
distribution,
and elimination.
If the rate of input
is known, the remaining
processes are well
described by the apparent
volume of distribution
and the clearance.
These parameters are
unique for a particular
drug. So, we're
talking about
particular drugs. drug
A is going to have
different apparent
volume of distribution
and clearance than
drug B or C or D or E.
And a particular patient,
so different
patients are going to
also have different
apparent volumes
of distribution
and clearance.
So these parameters
have average values
in the large
population that can be
used to predict
drug concentrations.
That's what
you're looking up
in your drug
monograph. It's a
great starting
place for you.
You don't have to guess.
Clearance of a drug
is the factor that
predicts the rate
of elimination in
relation to the
drug concentration.
Volume of
distribution is the
proportionality constant
that relates the total
amount of drug in
the body to the
plasma concentration
at a given moment.
Change in blood
flow to various
tissues changes
the rate of drug
distribution
to the tissues.
Thus, the effect of
a drug at various
sites of action
can vary depending
on the perfusion
of these sites.
Removal of a drug
by an organ can be
specified as the
extraction ratio,
the capacity of
that organ to remove
the drug, the fraction
or percentage of
drug removed by the
perfusing blood, or
sorry, removed from
the perfusing blood
during one passage
through the organ.
The bioavailability
of a drug is the
fraction of the
administered dose that
actually reaches the
systemic circulation.
The area under the
concentration versus time
curve describes the
measured concentration
of drug in the systemic
circulation as a
function of time from
zero to infinity as an
integration of the
concentration over time.
The concentration
of drug appearing
in plasma occurs
over time,
and it can be
used to calculate
bioavailability
clinical application so
here are some terms
I invite you to pause
the computer look at
the terms see if you
can come up with which
one goes where and
here are the answers
drug products that
contain the same acts
of ingredients and
are identical in
strength or concentration
dosage form and route
of administration.
So what are we looking
at? Same active
ingredients, same
strength, same dosage
form, same route
of administration.
Two drugs that fit
that description.
And that is called
pharmaceutical
equivalent.
Those are the
pharmaceutical
forms of those drugs.
Bioequivalent drug
products having
similar safety
and efficacy.
Safety and efficacy
is the key term
here for therapeutic
equivalence.
Biosimilar
products, it's a
biosimilar
product and meets
standards for
interchangeability.
And this is called
a biosimilar.
Please know these
terms. They are
described in the
notes handout, too.
Biological product,
highly similar to an FDA
-approved biological
product, and having
no clinically meaningful
differences in safety
and efficacy from the
reference product.
Oh,
biosimilar.
The difference
here is the
interchangeability.
In other words,
if I am giving
biologic product by
the name of
Rituximab, by the name
of Rituxin, which
is the brand,
and I want to give
another protein product
of Rituximab, which is
what Rituxin is, made
by a different company,
I want to make sure
that they're going to
have the same effect.
So they are
interchangeable.
And this is the FDA
definition. And I want
to tell you right
now, the FDA is
evaluating its definitions
on these biologic
products, these protein
products. So what
you're seeing here
may be different by
the time you actually
get into practice.
So, pharmaceutically
equivalent drug
products show no
significant difference
in the rate and
extent of absorption
of the active
pharmaceutical agent.
So, they're called
bioequivalent.
This is different
from the
therapeutic equivalent
because of the
safety and
efficacy component.
But two drugs that
are the same drug
in the same form,
and they have the
same rate and extent
of absorption,
are called bioequivalent.
And that concludes
part one of
our clinical
pharmacokinetics.